look like the pacific northwest outside
with all the
cloud cover we had unfortunately we just
didn't have any rainfall 62 degrees the
high for the day today
thick cloud cover with cool conditions
but compare that to the midwest the
central part of the u.s just getting hit
hard
with that arctic cold air seeping in
from canada one degree was our high in
bismarck indeed wind chill readings
at -21 in fact they have wind chill
advisories
all the way extended until valentine's
day i mean look at these numbers that
they've been seeing
minus 13 right now for bismarck twin
cities at -11 these are your wind chill
readings this is what it feels like on
your skin
when the wind is blowing and that cold
arctic air is seeping all the way down
to dallas at 23 degrees right now while
here we're sitting pretty
in those low 60s even with the cloud
cover we're nice and mild
and we're right near average 61 in
centennial hills for our current
temperature that includes sky canyon
55 for summerlin 63 downtown and north
las vegas aliante you're checking in 61.
64 for sunrise manor green valley 64.
henderson also at 64 rhodes ranch and
mountains edge
southern highlands all right right
around 61 degrees at this
5 o'clock hour 61 also for prompt 62 for
those of you joining us from boulder
city just shy of 70 right now for
laughlin but at least your winds are
fairly light radar network does show
some showers out there and even some
snow flurries
coming down here into utah these right
here are pretty much just
high level moisture not really coming
down and anything does come down it's
just evaporating before it
reaches the ground so we're just seeing
clouds more bark than bite
there are several systems that we're
watching out here in the gulf of alaska
that will impact us this week not
necessarily just
yet but by the time we get to friday the
chances for showers goes up a little
more according to our futurecast here
and then we get a bit of a break through
most of saturday saturday night though
we could see some rain drops return
and that includes also early sunday
morning with the possibility of rainfall
as well
and then we'll clear out those showers
by monday even as early as
sunday afternoon or evening tonight 49
degrees overnight still cloudy but we're
staying cool and dry
68 for tomorrow now here's the deal with
tomorrow we'll have clouds in the
morning
and then sun as the day progresses so
we'll be back to sunny skies later on
in the day for tomorrow maybe as early
as midday here's your most accurate
eight day forecast you're eight on eight
up to 70 on thursday
and then the numbers start to drop with
those systems they'll be coming in
breezy winds friday with a slight chance
for showers then possibly saturday night
and sunday two
and then back to sunshine this time next
week brian
all yours all right thanks ted